it's the holiday season now but you
wouldn't know it from the way my desk
and our studio looks I mean we yeah
no lights no tinsel we got nothing wow
it's it's a busy time yeah haven't had
real time to get so busy crafting this
beautiful show that we make every night
that we've been much too busy yeah yeah
that was meant to be silly anyway but
you know it happens people get too busy
to decorate so don't worry Andy I've
taken care of it I hired a super fast
holiday decorating pit crew and yeah
this year as part of Google's small
thanks program that's right we've
reached out to a local small business to
give us a hand
they're called Christmas brothers
they're based right here in Los Angeles
they help homes and businesses all over
Southern California decorate for the
holidays so I called them up they're
gonna get my desk in the holiday spirit
in record time you folks ready for this
we're gonna do this in record
this is incredible Wow Andy you look
fantastic thank you
I feel like Lucille Ball getting ready
for bed yeah no one understands what
you're this is fantastic look at that
guy go
yeah that's la transit that's public
transit you in LA it gets you from this
block to six blocks away and that's it
yeah oh you get anyway I think this
looks pretty nice yeah yeah our thanks
to thanks to our thanks to the Christmas
brothers for helping us out brother
thank you Christmas brothers if you know
a small business that deserves
recognition this time of year give them
a shout-out with the hashtag small
thanks it's a nice thing to do we'll
take a little break when we come back
James Franco
[Applause]
you